je crois qu'il faut simplifier celle que l’on a déjà.
Cette question et la réponse ne sont pas nouvelles pour notre langue,
elles ressurgissent depuis des siècles, depuis longtemps,
en 1492, dans la première grammaire castillane,
Antonio de Nebrija établit pour notre orthographe, une règle claire et simple :
« Nous devons écrire comme ça se prononce
et prononcer comme ça s’écrit. »
A chaque son, doit correspondre une lettre
et à chaque lettre doit correspondre un son,
et pour celles qui ne correspondent à aucun son,
elles devraient être supprimées. »
Le critère phonétique
disant qu'il faut écrire ce qui se dit,
ceci est et n'est pas, dans la base de notre orthographe d'aujourd'hui.
L'espagnol contrairement à d'autres langues
comme l'anglais ou le français,
a toujours montré une forte résistance
à s’écrire différement de sa prononciation
et ce n'est pas parce qu'au 18e siècle,
il avait été décidé d'uniformiser notre écriture,
il y a eu un autre critère qui guida une bonne partie des décisions,
le critère étymologique,
qui dit que nous devons écrire
les mots comme ils s'écrivent dans leur langue d'origine,
en latin, en grec.
Il nous reste le H muet, que nous écrivons mais que nous ne prononçons pas,
il nous reste le long B et le V court,
qui contrairement à ce que croient beaucoup de gens,
ils ne se sont jamais distingués dans la prononciation espagnol,
il nous reste le G aspiré comme dans « gente »
ou léger, comme dans « gato ».
Il nous reste le C, S, et Z,
trois lettres qui dans leur contexte peuvent correspondre à un son
ou parfois à deux, mais jamais à trois.
Je ne vous ai rien dit
que vous ne sachiez déjà de par votre expérience personnelle.
Nous sommes tous allés à l'école,
tous, nous avons consacré beaucoup de temps à notre apprentissage,
beaucoup de ce temps du cerveau plastique et infantile
en dictées,
et à mémoriser des règles orthographiques complètes, mais pleines d'exceptions.
Il nous a été transmis, de manière implicite et explicite,
l'idée qu'au travers de l'orthographe,
il y avait un enjeu fondamental dans notre formation.
Néanmoins, j'ai l'impression
que les professeurs ne se demandaient pas pourquoi cela était si important,
et aussi, ils ne se posaient pas la question préalable :
quel est le rôle de l'orthographe ?
A quoi sert l'orthographe ?
En fait, lorsqu'on se pose la question,
la réponse est plus simple et moins transcendantale
qu'il n'y paraît.
L'orthographe sert à uniformiser l'écriture,
qu’elle soit la même pour tous
et à ce que ce soit facile de nous lire.
Contrairement à d'autres aspects de la langue,
comme la ponctuation par exemple,
en orthographe, il n'y a aucune expression personnelle,
avec la ponctuation, si.
Avec la ponctuation, je peux choisir de changer le sens d'une phrase,
je peux donner un rythme particulier à ce que je suis en train d'écrire,
avec l'orthographe, non.
Avec l'orthographe, ou c'est juste, ou c'est faux,
selon que l'on se conforme, ou pas, aux règles en vigueur.
Donc, ne serait-il pas plus logique de simplifier les normes en vigueur
pour qu'il soit plus facile d'enseigner,
d'apprendre et d'utiliser l'orthographe correctement ?
Ne serait-il pas plus logique de simplifier les normes en vigueur ?
Pour que tout le temps
qui est consacré aujourd'hui, à l'enseignement de l'orthographe,
puisse être utilisé pour d'autres interrogations sur la langue,
dont la complexité mériterait du temps et de l'effort ?
Ce que je propose n'est pas d'abolir l'orthographe
ou que chacun puisse écrire comme il veut.
La langue est un outil dont l’usage est commun,
et pour cela,
il me semble fondamental qu'elle soit utilisée selon des critères communs.
Mais aussi, il me semble fondamental
que ces critères communs soient les plus simples possibles,
car si nous simplifions notre orthographe,
nous ne la nivelons pas vers le bas ;
cela n'a pas de conséquence sur la qualité de la langue.
Je travaille tous les jours avec la littérature du siècle d'or,
je lis Garcilaso, Cervantes, Gongora, Quevedo,
qui parfois écrivent « hombre » sans le « h »,
qui parfois écrivent « escribir » avec un « b » court,
et il est clair
que la différence entre ces textes et les nôtres est conventionnelle
ou c’est un manque de convention de leur époque,
mais pas un manque de qualité.
Permettez-moi de revenir aux professeurs,
les personnages clés de cette histoire.
Je mentionnais un peu plus tôt cette insistance irréfléchie
avec laquelle les professeurs nous enfonçaient
avec l'orthographe.
Ce qui est sûr, les choses étant ce qu'elles sont,
cela fait totalement sens.
Dans notre société,
l'orthographe fonctionne comme l'indice d'un privilège
qui permet de distinguer le cultivé de la brute, l'éduqué de l'ignorant,
indépendamment du contenu écrit.
Une personne peut obtenir ou ne pas obtenir un travail
à cause d'un « H » qu'il aurait mis ou pas.
Quelqu'un peut être l'objet de moqueries publiques
à cause d'un « B » mal placé.
De fait, dans ce contexte,
il est utile d'accorder tout ce temps à l'orthographe.
Mais il ne faut pas oublier
qu'au cours de l'histoire de notre langue,
il y a toujours eu des professeurs
ou des affiliés à l'enseignement des premières lettres
qui ont fait progresser les réformes orthographiques,
qui se sont rendu compte que notre orthographe
pouvait avoir des barrières pour la transmission de ce savoir.
Dans notre cas, par exemple,
Sarmiento avec Andrés Bello a facilité la plus grande réforme
de l'orthographe espagnole,
celle du Chili, au milieu du 19e siècle.
Pourquoi ne pas prendre le pari de ces professeurs,
et commencer à avancer avec notre orthographe ?
Moi, ici, dans l'intimité où nous sommes, 10 000,
je voudrais mettre sur la table quelques modifications
qui me semblent raisonnable de discuter.
Éliminons le H muet, là où il s’écrit,
si on ne prononce rien, on n'écrit rien.
(Applaudissements)
Il me serait difficile de comprendre
un éventuel attachement
face à toutes les lourdeurs causées par le H muet.
Le B long et le V court, dont nous parlions plus tôt,
ne se sont jamais distingués,
(Applaudissements)
prenons-en une,
et parlons-en,
chacun aura ses préférences, chacun pourra argumenter.
Choisissons-en une et éliminons l'autre,
G et J, séparons-en leurs fonctions,
que le G garde un son léger : « gato », « mago », « águila »
et que le J garde un son aspiré :
« jarabe », « jirafa », « gente », « argentino ».
Le C, S, et Z sont des cas intéressants,
ils démontrent que la phonétique peut servir de guide
sans pouvoir être une règle absolue.
Il faut faire attention aux différentes prononciations.
Maintenant, et comme je le disais avant, C, S, et Z
peut correspondre à un ou à deux sons,
et si, de trois lettres, on passe à deux, nous n'en serons tous que meilleurs.
Pour certains, ces changements peuvent paraître un peu drastiques,
ils ne le sont pas tant que ça.
L'Académie Royale Espagnole et toutes les académies des langues
croient que l'orthographe doit évoluer et être modifiée,
la langue est liée à l'histoire et aux traditions et coutumes,
c'est aussi un outil, une pratique à l'usage quotidien
et parfois en s'attachant à l'histoire, aux traditions, aux coutumes,
elle devient un obstacle dans l’usage d’aujourd’hui.
Ceci explique que notre langue,
en plus de celles que nous connaissons, en plus de celles qui nous sont proches,
a été modifiée au cours de l'histoire,
par exemple, nous sommes passé de « orthographia » à « ortografía »,
de « theatro » à « teatro », de « quantidad » à « cantidad »,
nous sommes passé de « symbolo » à « símbolo »
et depuis peu, il est retiré quelques H muets
dans le dictionnaire de la royale académie,
« arpa » et « armonía » peuvent s'écrire avec ou sans H,
ainsi nous avons tous juste.
Il me semble aussi que c'est un moment particulièrement approprié
pour aborder cette discussion.
On nous dit toujours que la langue change spontanément
du bas vers le haut,
que ce sont les utilisateurs qui incorporent des mots nouveaux
et des modifications grammaticales,
et que les autorités quelque part dans l'académie,
dans les pages du dictionnaire, dans un lieu du ministère,
longtemps après, les acceptent en les incorporant.
Ceci est vrai, à certains niveaux de la langue,
c'est vrai au niveau lexical, au niveau des mots,
c'est moins sûr au niveau grammatical,
et je dirais que ce n'est pas vrai au niveau orthographial
qui historiquement a toujours changé du haut vers le bas.
Ce sont toujours les institutions
qui ont établi les normes et qui ont proposé des modifications.
Pourquoi je trouve ce moment particulièrement approprié ?
l'écrit a toujours été utilisé de façon plus restreint et privé que l'oral,
mais à notre époque, celle des réseaux sociaux,
cela souffre d'un changement révolutionnaire.
On a jamais autant écrit que maintenant,
on a jamais autant écrit à la vue d'autant de gens,
et dans ces réseaux sociaux pour la première fois,
nous voyons à grande échelle des usages innovants de l'orthographe
où même des gens avec une orthographe impeccable, hyper-éduqués,
lorsqu'ils écrivent sur les réseaux sociaux, leur comportement
devient semblable à la majorité des autres usagers.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils relâchent la correction orthographique
pour privilégier la rapidité et l'efficacité de leur communication.
Il y a aussi des usages chaotiques, isolés,
il me semble que nous devons y prêter attention
car, probablement, cela nous indique
que l'époque qui donne une nouvelle place à son écriture,
requiert pour cette écriture de nouveaux critères.
Je crois qu'il serait mal de les rejeter, de les écarter
car nous les identifions comme
les symptômes d’une décadence culturelle de notre époque.
Non, je crois qu'il faut les observer, les classer et en connaître les causes
pour avoir une réglementation plus proche des besoins de notre époque.
J'anticipe quelques objections.
Il y aura ceux qui diront
que si nous simplifions l'orthographe, on perdra l’étymologie,
si nous voulions conserver l'étymologie de rigueur,
on n'y arriverait pas avec l'orthographe,
et en plus, il faudrait apprendre le latin, le grec, l'arabe.
Avec une orthographe simplifiée,
on peut conserver l’étymologie
au même endroit,
dans les dictionnaires étymologiques.
Une seconde objection sera celle de ceux qui disent :
« Si nous simplifions l'orthographe,
nous ne pourrons plus distinguer
les mots qui se différencient par une seule lettre. »
C'est vrai, mais ce n'est pas un problème.
Notre langue a des homonymes, des mots qui ont plusieurs sens,
sans confondre,
« el banco », le banc pour s’asseoir
« el banco », la banque,
« el traje » le costume de « trajer », rapporter quelque chose.
Dans la plupart des situations, le contexte dissipe la confusion.
Il y a une troisième objection,
elle est pour moi la plus compréhensible et la plus émouvante.
Ils disent : « Je ne veux pas changer,
j’ai été éduqué comme ça et je suis habitué à cette manière,
quand je lis un mot écrit en orthographe simplifiée,
ça me fait mal aux yeux. »
(Rires)
Cette objection, en partie, est en chacun de nous,
et moi, qu'est-ce que je crois que l'on devrait faire ?
Ce qu'on a toujours fait dans ce cas,
les changements se font par l'avant : on apprend aux enfants les nouvelles normes ;
et ceux qui nous aiment,
nous laissent écrire
comme à notre habitude
en espérant que le temps
y cimentera les nouvelles normes.
Le succès de toute réforme orthographique qui touche des habitudes autant enracinées
se fait dans la prudence, le consensus, la graduation et la tolérance
mais on ne peut pas non plus laisser faire que ce lien aux vielles habitudes
nous empêche d'avancer.
Le meilleur hommage que nous pouvons rendre au passé,
c'est d'améliorer ce que nous en recevons.
Donc, je crois que l’on doit se mettre d'accord,
que les académies doivent se mettre d'accord,
pour nettoyer notre orthographe de toutes ces habitudes
que l'on utilise après les avoir reçues, mais qui ne nous servent à rien.
Je suis convaincue que si l'on fait cela
dans un cadre modeste mais très important de la langue,
nous laisserions aux générations futures
un meilleur avenir.
(Applaudissements)